this
giant cruise ship in port everglades
florida
is royal caribbean's odyssey of the seas
preparing
to begin its first passenger cruise in
early july
meanwhile two passengers on board the
celebrity millennium
are in isolation after testing positive
for covid19 that ship
left st martin on saturday and all
adults on board were vaccinated
underscoring that keeping people safe on
these ships can be a challenge
the cdc recommends 95 percent of all
cruise passengers
be vaccinated when sailing from american
ports
resumes this month but republican
governors of florida and texas
are refusing to let companies require
passengers to prove
they've been inoculated errol barnett is
in port canaveral florida
errol good morning to you hey there good
morning how about one of the largest
cruise vessels in the world
as a backdrop right this demonstrates
how big of a business this is nearly
nine and a half million americans
embark on cruises here in florida and in
texas
in a typical year that's more than
two-thirds of the overall u.s
market but now there's intense confusion
in those locations
royal caribbean is strongly recommending
passengers be vaccinated for some of
its trips while norwegian and carnival
are following cdc recommendations
in requiring vaccinations for some of
their trips and basically this is now
leading to a
showdown in the states after 15 months
of a cdc
no sail order cruise ships around the
u.s
are poised to welcome back vacationers
royal caribbean group ceo richard fain
is
eager to see americans embark on one of
his vessels from port everglades in two
weeks
that's very exciting but i'm still
confused about the details involved
in getting us there but after the cruise
industry spent over a year negotiating
with the cdc on how to safely protect
against covid
and prevent super spreader events
there's another wave of resistance
people are going to cruise one way or
another it's a question is are we going
to do it out of florida which is the
number one place to do it in the world
are they going to be doing out of the
bahamas or other locations florida
governor ron desantis sued the cdc
to permit u.s based cruises in the
spring
then last month the republican signed an
executive order
prohibiting businesses from requiring
vaccinations
a key cdc recommendation for sailing
desantis is levying a five thousand
dollar fine per
violation so one cruise ship could
potentially incur
millions of dollars in penalties and on
monday
texas governor greg abbott followed in
florida's wake
even though carnival cruise lines had
announced a vaccinated
only cruise from galveston that same day
no business or government entity can
require a person to provide a vaccine
passport
or any other vaccine information as a
condition
of receiving any service or entering any
place
before covet more than 10 billion
dollars in direct spending was generated
by the cruise industry
in texas and in florida nearly half of
annual cruise spending
in the us cruise lines are eager to earn
some of that back what do you make of
what cruise lines are trying to do
to get back to business they're sort of
between a rock and a hard place
attorney michael winkelmann represents
cruise passengers and staff in legal
disputes
neither of these governors are members
of the cbc neither of them operate a
cruise line
i think they essentially need to keep
out of this and let the cdc and the
cruise lines continue to work together
so that people can get back to cruising
safely it's a sentiment shared by most
prospective cruise passengers
roughly 60 percent prefer mandatory
vaccines according to a recent harris
poll
only 23 percent prefer they not be
mandatory
oliver max in texas would be on a cruise
right now with his family
if it weren't for this cruise conflict i
think that
if there's not a vaccination requirement
that i will wait a few months and
wait to see what happens i believe in
the cruise industry to take care of
people
cbs news travel advisor peter greenberg
says cruise lines can decide to move
their business
elsewhere we have 17 ports in the united
states where cruise ships are operating
before the pandemic
if you're not going to have vaccinations
as a requirement people are going to
make other choices
it is just unclear where all of this
goes from here but it was just announced
yesterday by carnival that the vessel
you see behind me the mardi gras
which is their biggest will set sail on
her maiden voyage
july 31st and everyone on board
will be vaccinated anthony errol thank
you i'm with that man who said you know
i would wait if if
if i didn't know that all the other
passengers were being backed up i would
wait as well i know it's a personal
decision we all decided to get it but
the people that don't get it i just
think you put others in jeopardy
but science is clearly on our side about
those of us who have gotten it yeah
and right now that's all we have to
operate with is the science well
especially on ships where you've seen
diseases spread before and you're in a
confined environment there's also a
legal question that will be worked out
here businesses require all sorts of
things of people walking in that's right
two drink minimum shirts and shoes yeah
vaccine that's right